you know one of the players who is good
enough to be in a super bowl if he was
on the right team and maybe the browns
will be the right team at some point
miles garrett the first overall pick in
the 2017 draft roger goodell mentioned
that there will be a meeting between
miles garrett and roger goodell early in
the off season to determine when
how if garrett will be reinstated we had
forgotten all about him i know that
moment that most troubling moment we've
ever seen during a game where a helmet
is removed and actually used as a weapon
against another player garrett's still
suspended but a meeting coming fairly
soon to determine what his status no
you're right it's kind of got lost in
the shuffle just within the season
everything like that but uh this will be
yeah remembered as one of the more
gruesome events in the history of the
nfl certainly i mean it just didn't look
good and you know what what was it what
week was that game mike pittsburgh
cleveland i mean about halfway november
thursday in november yeah right so
you know again do you think he deserves
to be reinstated at this point do you
think this is something that should go
into the to the next season you know
again i know like this is not a bad guy
miles garrett i get that he's got a
little bit of a reputation for late hits
on quarterbacks all right but that to me
again was like one of the most egregious
things we've ever seen in the history of
the sport
and i'm going to say i also don't love
the way he handled it after that i don't
but uh
you know again i want to see a talented
guy get back on the field who i do think
his heart is in a good place i guess
that's what i wanted to say i'm not in a
position to assess whether or not he
deserves to be put back on the field
because what the nfl needs to decide
through the course of talking to him and
otherwise getting to the bottom of what
caused it in the first place
are you confident that whatever fuse
blue for miles garrett during that game
in that fateful moment right not blow
again because look there's a liability
component to all this and the nfl is
worried about liability to players and
it should be if you put a guy back on
the field
that you know or should know has the
propensity to remove someone's helmet
and use it against them as a weapon and
the next time around the guy is actually
seriously injured they got very lucky
really rudolph was not seriously injured
or worse by that blow to the head with a
helmet it's actually amazing it's
actually amazing that his head didn't
just split at least split open in some
degree and and blood started finding
enjoy your breakfast yeah thank you good
morning eggs and ketchup sky sports this
is later in the day yeah that doesn't
make it happen oh okay but the point is
this you have to dot every i and cross
every t before you let miles get it back
on the field so there will be pages and
pages of assessments of miles garrett is
this guy someone who is a risk to do it
again because if you put him back on the
field and he does it again the
argument's going to be
you knew he could have done it because
he's already done it you're right or you
blew the evaluation of the human being
and where he's at mentally and and the
fact that he might do it you're right
that would be huge repercussions for the
nfl no one has ever done what he did
specifically we've seen guys swing
helmets right but we've never seen
someone actually make contact with that
helmet and you need to be sure he will
never do it again no matter what the
stress is no matter what the frustration
is no matter what is said or not said
you need to be 100 sure he's not going
to do it again and you ultimately need
to be able to sell to a jury if it comes
to it that you did everything in your
power to conclude that he wasn't going
to do it again but the problem is if he
does it again that that proves that you
failed well yeah because the fact that
he does it again hey you failed to
determine that there may be a chance he
does it again and that's why and we go
back to this whole concept of it's a
privilege to play in the nfl if it is a
privilege right and that's why i said
initially yeah they have forfeited his
privilege forever because you can't put
a guy back on the field who's done what
he did right well uh yes you're right
all right there's a few not not that
that's the outcome no at some point
they're gonna let them back on the field
you're right but they need to protect
themselves before they right i mean
again there's a few things for you know
one yeah that the whole thing was bad i
don't like the way he handled himself
after it either i don't i don't i like
some of the accusations that flew there
and i don't know whether they're true or
not but they didn't the the argument
didn't match up to me okay but two i
don't think this is a guy with like real
malice in his life you know this is a
guy that what earlier in this year had a
fan punch him in the face in the car
right and he did nothing you know so uh
and then the other thing i would throw
into this you know miles garrett
again i'm all for i think he's paid his
his
paid the time he did the time for the
crime right i think i think you should
reinstate
that i know you just have to i'm sure
he's not going to do it again i get you
i know that and i'm just saying i'm just
trying to say just give a little
perspective of the player too you know
it's a guy that's had no off field
issues you know had a few late hits with
the quarterbacks that we mentioned
earlier earlier in the season and i just
mentioned it earlier in the show but i
mean miles gary's got to know if
something like this happens one more
time he's going to be done forever in
football he'll be done
he'll be banned for life if anything
remotely close happens to what he did
there so hopefully that rings true to
miles garrett i want to see him back on
the field first off you know hey listen
the cleveland browns got talent he's one
of the better defensive players in the
all of football
but i hope he learned his lesson and
yeah you're right the nfl has to be
careful about when they throw him out
there again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports